السنويه مؤتمر ميونخ للامن يعقد يعني
اجتماعه هو فعاليته اليوم بحضور العشرات
من القاده ما الهدف من هذه الفعاليات
ومرهانات هذا المؤتمر السنوي
طبعا سنستمع للكثير من الخطابات
والتصريحات حول اوكرانيا ودعم اوكرانيا في
مواجهه روسيا هذا المنتدى مؤتمر ميونخ
للامن في دورته التاسعه والخمسين وداد
مخصص على للامن في اوروبا لكن في السنوات
السابقه شكل نوع من فضاء للحوار مع مشاركه
روسيا مشاركه ايران كان هناك حوار وتراشق
احيانا هذه السنه اتخذ قرار بعدم دعوه
روسيا عدم دعوه ايران بالعكس دعوه معارضين
روس ومعارضين ايرانيين وكانه يبدو الى حد
كبير تجمع لقاده غربيين بشكل اساسي يمكن
ان يكون هناك على هامش المنتدى شيء من
الحوار الى اجتمع مثلا وزير الخارجيه
الصيني مع الامريكي على ضوء التوتر لكن في
المضمون سيكون العنوان الاوكراني هو
الابرز بعد 15 عاما من خطاب شهير للرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين هنا في هذا المكان
عام سبعه عندما انتقد الهيمنه الغربيه
الهيمنه الامريكيه بشكل خاص واعلن عوده
روسيا الى الساحه الدوليه ووضع حد لم
اعتبره
الهيمنه الاحاديه القطب وانتقد بشده تمدد
الاطلسي باتجاه الشرق بعد 15 عاما تغيب
روسيا عن هذا اللقاء عن هذا المؤتمر وتحضر
في النقاشات بشكل اساسي من باب انتقاد
ومهاجمه روسيا بطبيعه الحال ودعم اوكرانيا
ومع الابناء ان الرئيس الاوكراني زيلينسكي
سيشارك اما في كلمه متلفزه او ربما بعض
البعض يقول قد يفاجئ تكون مفاجاه بحضوره
شخصيا اليوم في المنتدى الذي سيفتتح بكلمه
لرئيس هذا المؤتمر من ثم للرئيس للمستشار
الالماني والرئيس الفرنسي وايضا الرئيس
الاوكراني ومستشاره النائبه الرئيس
الامريكي كما لها تشارك في هذا المنتدى
ايضا جزيل الشكر لك وسيمه الاحمر
شكرا لك